so now we're going to attempt to take
the derivative of the sine of the
natural log of x squared so now we have
a function that's the composite of a
function that's a composite of another
function so one way you can think of it
if you set f of X f of X is being equal
to sine of X and G of X G of X being the
natural log of X the natural log of X
and that's the F G let's say H of X H of
X equaling x squared then this thing
right over here is the exact same thing
as trying to take the derivative with
respect to X of F of F of G of F of G of
H of X of H of X and what I want to do
is kind of do think about it how I would
do it in my head without having to write
all the chain rule notation so the way I
would think about this if I were doing
this my head is the derivative of this
outer function of f with respect to the
the level of composition directly below
it so the derivative of sine of X is
cosine of X but instead of it being
cosine of X it's going to be cosine of
cosine of whatever was inside of here so
it's going to be cosine of natural log
let me write that in that same color
cosine of natural log of x squared x
squared don't do X in that same yellow
color cosine of x squared x squared and
so you could really view this this part
what I just write over here as as f
prime that this is F prime of G of H of
X this is f prime of G of H of X G of H
of X if you want to keep track of things
so I just took the derivative of the
outer with respect to whatever was
inside of it and now I have to take the
derivative of the inside with respect to
X but now we have another composite
function so we're going to multiply this
times we're going to the chain rule
again
the derivative of we're going to take
the derivative of Ln with respect to
x squared so the derivative of Ln of X
is 1 over X but now we're going to have
1 over not X but 1 over x squared 1 over
x squared so to be clear this part right
over here this part right over here is G
prime of not X if it was G prime of X
this would be 1 over X but instead of an
X we have our H of X there we have our x
squared so it's G prime of x squared and
then finally we can take the derivative
of our of our inner function let me
write so we could write this as G prime
of H of X G prime of H of X and finally
we just have to take the derivative of
our innermost function with respect to X
so the derivative of 2x with respect to
the derivative of x squared with respect
to X is 2x so times H prime of X let me
make everything clear so this let me see
so what we have right over here in
purple this this and this are the same
things 1 expressed concretely 1
expressed abstractly this this and this
are the same thing expressed concretely
and abstractly and then finally this and
this are the same thing expressed
concretely and abstractly but then we're
done all we have to do is simple to be
done is to just simplify this so if we
just change the order in which we're
multiplying we have 2x over x squared so
I can cancel some out so this x over X
2x over x squared is the same thing as 2
over X and we're multiplying it times
all of this business so we're left with
2 over X this goes away 2 over x times
the cosine of the natural log of x
squared so it seemed like a very
daunting derivative but we just say ok
what's the derivative of sine of
something with respect to that's
something well that's cosine of that
something and then we go in one layer
what's the derivative of that something
well and that's something we have
another composition so the derivative of
Ln of X or Ln of something with respect
to another something well that's going
to be one over the something so we had
gotten a one over x squared here that
that that squared got canceled out and
then find the derivative of this inner
most function it's like peeling an onion
the derivative of this inner function
with respect to X which was just 2x
which we got right over here this was 1
over x squared this was 2x before we did
any cancelling out so hopefully that
helps clear things up a little bit